- I really want you guys to smell the arm
- I'm not smelling your fingers.
- Please,
- No
- Get that shit away from me!
(exhales loudly)
- Put his nose in it.
(groans)
(soft music)
What's up you salty salmon slices.
Welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste Podcast.
- I'm sorry, what?
- What was that?
- Yeah you heard me right.
- Where did you
come up with that?
That's gonna be every
time I host an episode
that's going to be my thing.
That's going to be the new intro.
- That's a thing now?
- Shut though, man we didn't
discuss this before hand.
(laughs)
- I was thinking of that
shift for like two weeks.
- What the fuck?
- I'm like this is gonna slap.
- That's the best you
came up with in two weeks?
- Hey man give me some time
well I'm working on it.
- All right.
- Well, welcome
to the trash taste podcast.
The show where we talk trash
about our tastes anatomy.
I'm your host for today, Joey
and joined as always is
Garnt and Connor dope.
- Yo.
- So this episode is I guess
the first special episode
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Speed off episode.
I mean if you're being linked
from our main channel videos,
hello, welcome to the podcast.
- Welcome.
- But if you haven't seen
our main channel videos
do we wanna explain what we did?
- Joey go on.
- Oh yeah, Sure.
So basically on our main channel
we decided to do like
a little fun challenge
where as you can see
our backdrop is a little bit burnt.
- This is a big table
that has a lot of potential space
to be filled out with some Weeby shit.
So what we decided to do is
we decided to venture out
into the weebland itself,
Akihabara in Tokyo
which is like known as like
heaven for tacos essentially.
- Yes it is. I can confirm.
- And we decided to
challenge ourselves to see
how many figurines or I guess anime merch
we can buy with a $500 budget
or about 50,000 Yen if
you convert it to Yen.
And just instead of just
going out and making it
like a vlog kind of thing,
we decided to turn it into a challenge
where we fight each other for brets.
- Let's make it fun.
- Let's make it challenging
and let's make, let's put
some stakes on this bitch.
(laughs)
- Let's make in a relaxing experience
with shopping into stressful hell
where you buy shit.
You don't want to meet
a dumb set of criteria.
Would you like to speak--
- Out of the money in our pocket.
(laughing)
- Yeah, exactly right.
- So essentially we gave
ourselves a number of challenges.
We had some small challenges that we did
in the four enemy stores that we went to
in our main channel videos.
Again, if you want to check
it out, go check it out.
- Yeah you miss a lot of context
if you don't watch that video.
But if you haven't seen it
and you refuse to for some reason,
you'll still be fine
to watch this podcast.
- Yeah. So basically we
all have scores already
from challenges that we went to,
that we did in each store
which is probably on screen right now.
- Yeah.
- You'd know that
if you've watched our videos
but here are all our scores.
- Yeah. All right it's not the final score
like any good Mario party game, right?
It doesn't matter how many
stars you end up with.
It's all about the final count.
- [Connor] Right.
- It's all about the bonus stars
and this episode is essentially
where we go over the bonus stars
as well as show each other what we got
because right now we don't know
what the fuck each other got.
- No.
- We maybe got like a few glimpses
as we like passed each
other passive aggressively
in each of the stores.
But right now we have no idea
what the other person bought.
So that's what we're
going to find out today.
So we have a bunch of
overarching challenges, right?
- Yes. So we have some that
are like pretty obvious
like who spent the most
on a single figurine.
What was else,
who bought a figure from
the most popular series,
which you lose a point if that's the case.
- Normy award.
- We'll go over every challenge at the end
after we've finished showing
everyone what we've bought.
But for now I just wanted to ask you guys,
we just filmed it yesterday.
- Yeah.
- How did you guys find the experience?
I mean, I found it super fun.
That came out like I haven't
started editing the video yet
as I'm recording this episode,
but I can already tell that video
is going to be so fucking fun to watch.
- Yeah, I feel like it's just fun.
Like that's like the, any way to,
you can see them having fun in it.
Cause it was just, I mean,
it's like a kid in a candy store, right?
- [Joey] Essentially.
- Like we always go to these stores.
- It's a very expensive candy store.
(laughs)
- Exactly.
- we always go to these stores
and being able to like film
in there, with permission.
You know, we want to do
that professionally as well.
We didn't Lo gang pull this
shit, if you know what I mean.
- We got permission because
we respek the country.
- Yeah. We, we got all
permission from the stores
and it's just great
because you kind of just got
to let loose in the store.
I mean, some of the stores
that have people in there
so I was still trying to be respectful,
but you know, like Animate,
there was no one else in that store.
- No.
- Just us.
- We, we got in like before
the store even opened so.
- When we left the store
there was like a massive queue.
- Of people trying to get in.
- And I was like, Oh, I
feel kind of bad right now.
(laughing)
- Felt so bad.
- Then we just come out just like
with all our crap and just being like
you guys have to lay on
(laughs)
- Look at these peasants.
- But yeah, like a lot of the stores
were like very happy to have us.
I mean like Amiami made us like
sign that like little thing
in that photo.
- Yeah, it was crazy.
- If you ever go to Amiami in Akihabara
look out for our little plaque.
- Yeah. We have a trash
tastes like plaque.
- Oh do you think they
going to hang that up?
Is that what the (laughs).
- I assume so.
- Yeah they should.
I really hope so.
But like no, but all of the
stores were super freaking cool.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- They were very supportive.
So there's first of all, big shout out
to all the stores that did give
us permission to film there.
But yeah, without further ado,
I think we should go over what we bought
in each store and judge our,
as the name suggest,
Trash Taste on figurines
and other anime merch.
- So let's just
jump right into it.
- Wait,
before we jump right into it.
(laughs)
- I wanna jump right into it.
- I can't wait to jump right into it.
(laughs)
- Oh my God
let's just hold off on
the jumping for a second.
I want to discuss,
so did you guys have any strategy,
going into this game or
into this challenge even?
- I said I did in my main channel video
but in retrospect I didn't.
(laughs)
- If I win, it was all a plan.
If I loose, I was just having
a fun time with the boys.
You know, I think that's...
Okay to be 100% honest,
I like had some idea
but I think it,
my strategy was just see
what you guys are doing.
So if you guys are trying
to go off all the challenges
and I could see you guys
with paying attention,
like, okay I was going
to, but if I knew that...
because I could tell
some of you, you know,
weren't paying as much attention
to the challenges as others.
I was just saying.
- The only challenge
that I paid in mind to
was only one that I remembered,
which was the whoever
gets closest to $500.
- Which is worth two points.
- Yeah which is like two points.
I'm like I have to prioritize that
because that two points is big.
- Two points is big but,
like I remember, because
I couldn't even remember
all the challenges we agreed on.
So I went to into the day being like,
okay, this one's an obvious challenge.
This one's an obvious challenge.
As I went into more stores,
I was like, I am not keeping track at all.
- I am running out of money.
I don't know what's happening.
- When I was in Animate,
I'm like, okay, I'm going
to do this in this store.
I'm going to do this and that store.
And then I hit the second store.
I'm like, what the fuck am I doing?
I have--
- I was so short-sided
on like the challenges
that I had to do in that store.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then I was just like
fuck the other challenge.
I need to get this.
- So to put it in perspective,
we've got two challenges for every store
as you probably saw in the video.
So which is a total of eight
points that we could get.
There's 11 points up for grabs
in the overarching challenges.
- [Joey] Yes.
- Yeah.
- So I mean, if you do really well
on the overarching challenges
it might not fucking matter.
- Yeah exactly. Like
we're all already close
from what we've already seen.
We're like maybe one or two points--
- Eight, seven, six.
- Yeah. So really close.
- So that's
a two point discrepancy.
- So right now
I might be losing
but like any good Mario party game,
I can always come back right at the end.
(laughs)
- So, yeah.
- Should we just jump right into it?
(all laugh heartedly)
- Let's jump right into it!
- So we start with Amiami,
oh no sorry, Animate first?
- [Garnt] We start with Animate.
- Animate!
- I didn't buy much in this store.
It was the first one
I didn't want to pull the trigger yet.
- Okay. So here's the thing about Animate.
I didn't know how much I should buy.
- We're just revealing right now
or what do we do?
I mean, who wants to go first?
I mean, okay.
Oh. Shit. Can I go first?
- You're the host.
- Okay, I'll go first
because I only bought
one thing at Animate.
- [Connor] All right, same.
So one of my challenges was
to get a Made in Abyss Figurine.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Couldn't find it. Not just at Animate.
Any of the stores, I couldn't find it.
(laughs)
So I just lost a point for that one.
But I figured, you know, what?
I'll get something like kind
of cool and kind of niche.
So I got a Chaiki Moto from Dororo.
- Oh damn!
- Oh wow, I didn't even know
they made for this.
- Yeah
- I know.
It's a ninderoid of a Chaiki Moto .
And I mean, Dororo was so fucking awesome.
Like I love Maimai Kamisama stuff,
and I love Dororo .
I was like, you know,
I like my ninderoids too so.
- You know what, not bad.
- It's really, really cute.
I mean, we'll probably figure
out the pose of it somehow
- But it's the stressful
thing about ninderoids.
So you just have to pick one pose
and that's...
(Garnt laughs)
We all know it's never going
to change from this pose.
- They're also so finicky as well
but once you've nailed it,
you're like hell yeah.
- Exactly.
- So that's the only
thing I got at Animate.
- Because, yeah, I got
a few things at Animate.
So I had two challenges, right?
And I think I got fucked
over some of the overarching challenges
by just Animate itself.
- [Joey] Really?
- Okay.
- So let's go ahead.
So the first thing, the first challenge
was to buy a Deku figure
from My Hero Academia.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- So as we all know
one of the overarching challenges
was the person who buys
a figure from the most
popular series gets deducted points.
So there's my deku figure.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I was actually getting
a bit worried, right?
Because there weren't many like figures
in Animate.
- No, there wasn't.
Animate was more like general merch.
- Yeah, it was really varied in--
- Yeah so the only thing I
could find on ninderoids.
And so my second challenge
was to ask a store clerk, in Japanese,
to recommend me a figure.
- Figure oh sumi.
Okay, yeah.
- You had to pull a sumi masen.
- Wait, what did he recommend you?
- Okay, he recommended to me Edward Elric
from Fullmetal Alchemist.
- No!
(all laughing)
- You've totally lost it.
- You've totally lost.
- I was like, whoa! Oh my God you've,
one, you recommend to me
the figure from the one series
I haven't seen yet, fucking.
(all laughing heartedly)
- You haven't seen it.
- Oh my God.
- That's so fucked.
- And two, you've just
made me all to lose a point
by recommending to me, I checked before,
for the fourth, most
popular anime series on mal!
So thank you for making
me lose the point.
- Oh my God.
- Wait, because I see the price there.
That's 48 bucks, right?
- Yeah.
- How much did you spend on these two?
Are they both 48 bucks?
- This one says 48,88.
And this one says--
- That was like about 52 bucks.
- Yeah, this one will be a
little bit more expensive.
- You got done dirty by that man.
- Yeah
(laughs).
In the video, I was like,
oh thank you very much
for recommending to me.
And inside I'm just like,
I can't believe you've done this.
(laughing)
And I bought one more thing,
which cracked me up,
which is an Ishtar plushie.
It's far Ishtar.
(laughs)
- [Joey] It's kind of cute.
- It's kinda cute I like it.
- Oh, from Fate?
- Yeah from Fate.
- Oh.
Okay, what the Fuck.
(laughs)
That's kinda cute.
- I think that's a,
what is it? It's called tsum.
It's like a, it's like a
giant tsum tsum, right?
- Yeah.
- I think that's the
thing that's over here.
Yeah. That's so cute though.
- That is very cute.
- Yeah. That's gonna look sick.
- So how much would you
spend on Animate overall?
- $120.
(Connor exhales)
- Jesus. I only spent--
- Wait this is 30 bucks.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I only spent 48.
- Yeah, so I also spent 48 bucks
on my red Cell fan.
- Oh, I was looking at that one.
- So my two challenges were
get a female figure
and get one from a show
that you watched recently.
And I watched like a few
episodes, like two months ago, so.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Why didn't you get the Nezuko figure?
I saw you eyeing the Nezuko and I'm like,
motherfucker, if I--
- He doesn't wanna lose the point.
- Yeah, I didn't wanna get the Normy award
And I knew that demon
slayers are the most normal.
Whatever the ranking say,
I would've lost the Normy award at heart.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
And plus you know, I
don't want to risk it.
And also I thought, you know,
it's kind of a cool figure,
you know.
- Yeah, it is.
If we have Nezuko
it makes us look like fake anime fans.
I'm just saying like.
- Nah, get the fuck out, man.
Nezuko
is best Imouto of last year.
- Whatever! Okay!
I think Garnt has like
fulfilled the prophecy
with these two.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- Literally the boomer of AniTube here.
Tell me about why Nezuko
is, you know, best--
- I've gone like how many episodes
and I've not talked about Iumoto here.
- Oh my God.
- And you are taking
this chance away from me.
- Just give us some time.
You know, Garnt's going to get there.
- I was thinking we'd just
put it in the front for now.
We'll just gather them
in the front for now.
- (laughing) I was very grounded.
- I, okay for the record,
I hate ninderoids.
I think ninderoids are
like stressful purchases.
- I love ninderoids.
- and we have four
goddamn ninderoids.
Because you have to pose them, right?
And, and the whole selling
point of a ninderoid,
I'm putting everybody
sponsored by ninderoid ever.
(laughs)
The whole selling point
of a ninderoid is that you can move it.
But tell me, everyone
who wants a ninderoid,
when have you changed
the pose of a ninderoid?
- I've changed it a few times.
- That's a lie.
It's a fucking lie.
- I've never changed it.
- Yes, he's lying.
- I've changed it because
I'm sponsored by those guys.
(laughs)
Thanks guys.
- It is stressful.
And then you've got to worry about the box
and the little things, and I just.
- I sometimes like, where I'm just like,
I look at the little parts and I'm like
I want to change it eventually.
And then I do.
And I'm like, okay, I'm glad I kept watch.
- Actually, before we go on,
question to you guys,
what do you do with a figure box?
Do you bin it or do you keep it?
- I store it.
- Shit man, I ripped that shit over.
- No!
Even after living in Japan
where the box is like half the value.
(laughs)
- Because yeah, the
mentality for me is like
if I eventually like
possibly get like, you know,
I lose interest--
- I'm gonna sell this figure.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- No Fuck off, you're not
going to sell the figure.
- That's me, I tried.
- Like this guy. I'm like maybe
I can sell this JoJo merch.
You don't know, fuck!
You'll never gonna sell that JoJo merch.
- All right, but here's the
other thing I do, right?
What helped me at my last place
is that it makes moving
house so much easier
if you keep the box.
- [Connor] Yeah, it's true.
- Because you'd like, I usually,
what I do at least with figurines, right?
Is like, I throw out like
the plastic like mould,
but I keep the box.
- Yeah, I don't even do that.
- I throw the plastic mould.
- It just takes up
so much space.
- But the thing is, if you
chuck out the plastic mould
and you flatten the box,
then when you like move house
you can just open the box up again
glad wrap it in,
and then boom.
- I'm just too lazy for that.
I just put it in the cupboard.
- You save so much time
and money and like possibly
like the risk of like ruining
a figurine when you move.
And like that saved me so much trouble
when I moved to my current house.
So that's why I hold onto it.
- [Connor] Right.
- Okay.
I said it's for repurposing.
It's like, it's not.
(laughing)
- Solid purchases there overall.
I think just makes a good taste.
- Yeah, I think, they're gonna look great.
- The next store--
- My favorite anime, Fullmetal Alchemist.
(laughs)
I recommend you guys, watch that.
- Your favorite character
from your favorite anime.
(heartedly laughing)
- Oh my God.
- But the next store we went to was Astop.
- I spent so much money here.
- Actually, okay. what were you...
Before we get to Astop,
what was you guys' strategy with Astop?
- Okay. Astop is probably the store
that I go to the most just casually.
- Yeah, I think for
all of us it's the same
So I knew I really had to spend time
just like looking around.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because there were so
many figurines at Astop
that I legitimately have
never seen anywhere else.
Even though they're
technically secondhand.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So I'm like, okay, I'm
going to aim for those.
And I think I got pretty decent solution.
- Because for me, Astop was
the most daunting shop, right?
Because, okay, so in my challenge
I had to squat 10 times
before entering the store.
- That's not a challenge.
- That was easy to do.
And my second challenge was an auto lose
beacause I had to buy
the most expensive figure
which we found out was like 1,000 bucks.
So I knew I was going to lose that.
So I was like, I was going into Astop
just not trying to complete any challenge
but just trying to like
buy figures that I like.
- That's not a certain.
- Yeah.
Follow your heart.
- Yeah. I kind of went
fucking mental in Astop.
(laughs)
- I filled up my piece of paper.
- No! Are you serious?
- Yeah.
- Yes, same here.
Okay. So like, because like with Astop
there are so many figures
and so many display cases
that you don't remember
which figure you saw where.
So my strategy was just
if I see a figure I like
I'm gonna write it down
and maybe I'll cross it out later.
I fucked myself over so much in there
because I was just like,
I remember seeing you
like halfway through.
And I filled up my entire sheet
and you didn't even have a piece of paper.
- I was still looking for like stuff.
- So I was just going, okay,
that one, okay write it down, write that.
And then I got to the end
and then I couldn't remember
which figure was which.
(laughs)
So I was trying--
- Yes, I heard that.
It was like, is it this one?
I think, it is maybe that one.
- Yeah. So it was like
basically trying to choose
between my children.
So I'm like, what the fuck
am I crossing out right now?
(Joey laughs)
I'm like, I have no fucking clue.
- Wow. Okay, because yeah,
like for me, like Astop
I knew if I wasn't careful at Astop
I was going to go absolutely ham
as I usually do just like casually.
So I'm like, okay, there
are still two stores left.
We're not even halfway
through this challenge
so I have to like limit myself
as much as possible at Astop.
So I only bought three things.
- Oh, okay.
- At Astop. How many did you get?
- I can't remember.
Like five, six.
- I mean, you'll see.
Do you want to go first then?
- Yeah, I'll go first.
- And then me and you can take in turns
showing one off each.
- Yeah.
I decided to like kind of
go for like smallest ones.
So my two challenges was the
first one was really easy.
I had to go up to the store clerk
and ask if they had Boku No Pico merch
which they said they didn't.
Thank God.
(Garnt laughs)
- Did they know what it was.
- The guy was in English speaking stuff.
So he's like, ''Is that the one
''where the two guys fucking?''
(all laughing heartedly)
You'll see it in the video.
But the other challenge was really easy.
It was just pick a figurine
that either myself Garnt or Connor likes.
So obviously I went with
the one that I liked.
- That's bullshit by the way.
- So mine is still in glad wrap right here
so I've got to unwrap this shit.
But I obviously
got my goddamn Waifu.
- Oh my God,
is it fucking Monogatari? Jesus.
- Of course it is.
- Look if I'm going to
be on this show casually
like all the freaking time
of course I needed to get my wife Shinobu,
but I actually don't even
have this one at home so.
- I guess, I'm just gonna go next now
because of course I
followed my heart as well.
(laughs)
- Oh my God you've got Monogatari as well?
- Hell yeah!
(laughing)
- Oh God. No my wife!
- So yeah, I knew Joey
would get a Shinobu figure
becaause I saw so many boxes
that were just purely Shinobu
and I'm just like, get
that shit out of me.
Get that shit out of my face man.
- You might need to like
hold it up to the camera
because they might not be seen.
There're even boxes in the way actually.
- So I mean like what I
tried to do at Astop was,
at the beginning I just tried to note down
as many figures as I
could for under 20 bucks
because I feel like anything over 20 bucks
was like kind of risking it in terms of--
- I mean especially if you're buying
like seven figurines on Astop.
- Exactly.
So this one's, I don't have this figure.
Because it's short hair Senjougahara.
- Oh, that's cute.
Dude I personally find the
short hair Senjougahara's
figurine so much nicer
than the long haired one.
- There was so many good
Senjougahara figurines.
So it like hurts me that I
had to buy the cheapest one.
- All right boys.
You wanna see what I bought then?
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- This is a...
I think it was a 900 Yen
sold out online figure.
- You didn't even get like
the good sold online one.
- It was the cheapest sold online figure
because you know, if
you're going to buy garbage
why care about which terrible item it is?
It was 900 Yen I think.
And it was the cheapest
sold online figure.
. [Joey] Oh damn okay.
- Was this for a challenge?
- Yeah. Remember? I had to shout
I freaking love SAO.
- While buying an SAO figure.
- I will say that shout
wasn't a shout at all.
- In Japanese culture
that was like full shout.
- That was just, okay,
''I freaking love SAO''
- No! It was louder than that.
- It was just like, ''I
freaking love SAO.''
It was like a gradual
like building volume.
- Let's get this boy out of here.
- Okay, the other two though that I bought
I think is super freaking cool
because they're two figures
that I personally really wanted but also
it's just like really--
- Sorry it's making noise
over here.
What did you say over there Joey.
Let's get the shit out of here.
- I think it goes without saying,
don't listen to the audio only of this.
It's going to sound probably horrible.
- Hey guys, just opening
a box over here, I mean.
- No. This is box opening ASM guys.
- Okay but let me show you
the other two I got, okay.
This second one I got is Shonen Jump.
- [Garnt] Oh, that's so cool.
- [Connor] Okay that's
pretty fucking cool.
- Right? Like I'd never seen this before
and I was like,
does this count as a figurine?
Probably does.
- Yeah. It's a piece of
you know, solid kind of--
- I love Shonen Jump
and that's gonna look so cool
on like the shelf or something like that.
- I think if we had a coolest item award
Because I didn't know
if we could get a coolest item over here.
- Because we have to all agree.
- Yeah. But I think we can all agree
this one of the coolest figurines.
And the other one I got
is also pretty cool.
It's Puck from Berserk.
- [Connor] Oh that's cool.
- Yeah. Look at how tiny this guy is.
- [Connor] How much was that?
- This was 980 Yen.
- Oh wow. Because every
Berserk figure I saw
was so expensive.
- Yeah.
- Like there's a few figures
in the store that I found.
It's like Nanachi,
the little Nanachi figure.
Nanachi was like 250 bucks.
- Oh yeah no, the Made in Abyss stuff
is so expensive.
- [Garnt] Yeah, because
it's so hard to find.
- So even I got that Made
in Abyss thing at Astop
I probably still wouldn't
have been able to do it
because I'm not going to spend
$250 on a Nanachi figure.
- Oh, Angel Beats!
- So I got Yuri from Angel Beats.
She was, I can't remember how much
but it was between 10 and 20 bucks.
- That's so cute.
- There's one figure
that I didn't get
I of course put Sagiri down.
(laughs)
I of course put Sagiri down
and you see my video
when I'm like trying to figure out
which figure is which
and I was like just crossing our figures.
The realization when I had crossed
out Sagiri was just like
my heart fucking sank, man.
My heart sank and I was like,
Oh no I crossed off sagiri.
How could I.
(laughing).
- Oh my God.
- Don't don't look at what I'm unboxing.
- I mean, this is essentially
all I bought at Astop.
I think I spent...
I didn't even spend $100 at Astop
I think because I spent 9,940 Yen at Astop
because this Shonen Jump one was 5,000 Yen
which is kind of
expensive but not too bad.
I mean I just tried to get Cindereys.
(laughs)
- You got another Ishtar piece?
- Yeah.
It's a double Ishtar,
two Ishtar.
- Oh my God
I think I even forgot her.
- I think it's like Medudine
or something like that.
- She's cute.
- It's probably written on the box.
I don't want to say I've
bought the single best figure
- But are you gonna tell.
- But what can you say?
(laughs)
Look at this $30 Mike Wazowski gem.
- That's actually so cool.
I actually love that.
- That's actually like
no joke, that's a good figure, right?
- I know, cause I saw Mike Wazowski like--
- I heard you shout it.
- And I was like, Mike,
what are you doing here?
- So I have, it was a $30 purchase
and I'm just want to
make you guys laugh here.
I just wanna--
- Can, I see that.
I actually love this.
- That's a good figure.
It's well made.
- I love this dude.
- Let me put this up here.
- I love how like
the base is the Monsters Inc logo.
- Yes! So good.
- That's so cool.
- I bought it for a troll
but I actually thought
it's not bad for 30 bucks.
- No that's actually,
I think our audience can appreciate that.
That's so cool.
I kind of want it. I love that.
(humming a tune)
- Well that's Toy Story, right?
- No, that's not--
- Do you have any more figures coming up?
- I have plenty of more figures.
- I mean, I'm all out
so I'm just going to watch you guys.
- You guys keep talking.
- Hell yeah! Megumin my Waifu.
- She was cheap, I think
she was like 19 bucks.
- Some Megumin figurines,
- It's a pretty big figure.
The form factor of this
box, it's pretty deceiving.
- That's one thing I have
noticed about Megumin figurines.
Some of them are like way
cheaper than what they should be.
- Yeah.
- It's hard to tell the difference
between an $80 Megumin figure
and a $20 Megumin figure.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's like, you know,
with some of the popular characters
there's like so many different prices
with some of the popular characters.
Because I think I was about to buy,
I was going to buy darkness as well.
So I thought Joey was
going to buy Megumin.
- I was too
- I thought about it
but I'm like, I don't need to
and I reckon one of your
guys is gonna buy her.
- Hold on.
- What?
- Has nobody bought any JoJo figures.
- Oh wow. It's funny you asked.
(laughs)
- Thank God!
- I would just like to preface that
that was not a scripted bid.
That was totally just coincidence.
- No, because we were just showing figures
and I remember thinking that
I say in the video, okay,
Connor is gonna buy JoJo figures.
I don't need to buy any JoJo figures.
So if he didn't buy any,
I would have been like
how did we go an entire fucking trip
to Akihabara without
buying any JoJo figures.
- I bought multiple JoJo figures actually
because of course I did.
- Okay, good. On brand.
- So this is the,
a figure that I've
actually never seen before.
This is the--
- Oh I saw that.
- Oh, Joey's destroying--
- I'm just destroying my set right now.
- This is the crazy diamond JoJo figure
and it's the one of the
special colored editions
actually, I think cause there's
a normal colored version
and I've never seen this figure before
and I've never seen it
listed anywhere or anything
but there was two of them
in the store funny enough.
And it was only like 19 bucks.
For 19 bucks that's a really nice figure
and if you've seen JoJo figures
- Some of them look absolutely--
- They charge a lot more for a lot less.
And it's tragic that
like a 20 bucks figure
for the special colored
edition is like way better
than I paid 120 bucks for--
- Also like the thing with JoJo figures
it's like a double-edged sword
it's that like some of them
just look like absolute ass.
- Some of them do not
look like the character
- Not at all.
- And it's kind of tragic
because it's like one
of the most influential
and popular series in Japan
and they do them dirty
but it's a good figure.
I mean, that's a beautiful
figure, right boys?
We can agree on that.
- That is a beautiful figure.
- All right boys should I show
my next figure that I bought?
I bought a lot at Astop.
I think I bought 10.
This is.
- Dude. I was going to buy that!
- I knew he was
because before we left the store, right?
And I don't know if we got this on camera.
I don't think we did.
But Joey was like, I'm was
going to buy this figure
and he pointed to the booth
where I got this figure
and he was like,
''Oh it must have been
in a different booth.''
And I was thinking, I fucking bought that.
- Yeah, the moment I like, I looked over,
it was like a comic.
I was like, I looked
over and it was just gone
and in my head I'm just
like, someone bought it.
- It is like --
- How much did that cost?
- [Joey] It was like 30 bucks.
- It was 30 bucks .
Look at how cool that is for 30 bucks.
- [Joey] It is so good.
- It is not standing up
I'm realizing now.
(Garnt laughing)
I wonder if the cape...
- Oh the cape.
- Guys for 30 bucks.
- I know.
- That's pretty fucking good.
- It's fucking steal.
- And like how often do
you see Akira figurines?
- Never.
- [Joey] That's pretty cool.
- For 30 bucks
that's fucking steal I think.
- Okay.
- Absolutely. That's very cool.
Oh, now it's standing up?
I guess now it's just--
(laughing)
- You got one?
- Oh yeah I got one.
This is my last figure.
I of course I wanted to fill this channel
with some degeneracy.
- [Joey] Of course.
- Oh what the fuck
did you buy.
- I think I know what you've bought.
- Just the question is
how much was I willing to spend on it?
And (laughing) this figure--
- What did you get. What's in the box.
Oh no I just had a breakdown.
Are you kidding me?
- [Joey] Yes!
- Rias really?
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
Do you wanna know how much
I spent on this figure?
- I don't think I wanna hear it.
- I think I walked past it
and I think I remember it
being way over my budget.
- How much?
- This was $170.
(laughing)
- Garnt, what the fuck!
- [Joey] Holy Shit.
- That's kinda hot though.
- When I saw it I was
like, I've got to get this.
Because, you know that
meme when you just like,
''How to help me budget this correctly.''
When I was going through the sheet
I was like crossing off
figures and Sydney was like
just get rid of the fucking
High School DxD figure.
I'm like, I'm not getting rid
of the High School DxD figure.
- She stays Sydney, you leave!
- I walked past this figurine in my video.
And I was like I would get this
if it wasn't $170
because I didn't want to go overboard.
But the moment I saw it, I'm like,
one of these fuckers is gonna buy it.
- That feel when I realized
that I don't have the
most expensive figure now.
(groans)
Breaks my heart.
All right, should we see what I got?
- Yeah.
- A piece of wing, another wing.
- [Joey] let me put that together.
- Oh this is in two parts. Okay
- So I was trying to put that together
underneath the table. It was pretty hard.
- Oh it's magnetic.
Okay. Yeah, because you have to do this.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
Yeah. What is this?
Oh shit. Okay.
- This is two in one figures.
Is this the dragon from Slime
- It is indeed. And it
comes with more parts?
- Holy shit I didn't realize
that Slime will be representing this much
because honestly like I
didn't put too much thoughts
into what I was trying to buy.
- [Joey] There we go.
- Holy shit this came with so many parts.
- I'm so glad you got Rimuru.
- [Joey] Oh, that's so cool.
- So this was actually--
Wait till we build it
but like this was a two in one figure.
I don't know if that counts
me buying two figures
or one.
I paid one, but it's two figures.
- I mean that's technically one right?
- No because they're not actually joined.
They were both sold together.
- [Joey] Oh, okay.
- So I guess how much
I paid for these two.
- 20 bucks.
- A little low bro.
I pay 30 bucks for the both of them.
- [Joey] Okay wow.
- Because I originally had a Meruem figure
and a Rimuru figure
which is 35 bucks.
- Was it just Rimumu on its own?
- No. It was like a bundle.
- With the dragon?
- No, It was just Rimuru
on its own with Meruem.
And then I decided to go against
that just to go for Meruem so--
- Well I'm glad that
we don't have a single
like character that's like overlaps.
- Yeah I'm surprised because I thought--
I thought at this point
we would at least have like
some dups of some characters
but we've miraculously
somehow gotten around that.
- Why is this head not going in?
What the fuck!
(laughs)
- This wing is not going in either.
(Joey laughs)
But yeah.
- Then he sold me
a faulty thing.
I'm joking, he was very nice to me.
- So is that everything you bought Connor?
- No, there's way more.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Do you wanna
try to assemble this while the next?
- [Joey] Yeah, give those.
- Get a look at that poor head.
- Oh my God (laughs) look at that.
- [Joey] Oh no man!
- My figure gone? I spent money on that!
But yeah, I thought.
- It's falling apart.
- I knew none of you
are going to get a Slime figure.
So I thought, you know, I'll get it.
Cause I thought also it's super blue
I thought that would
look sick on the podcast.
- So like how much did you
spend on all these figures?
We'll find out later
because this is the store
I spent the most stuff.
- I thought because when I
finished going through the store
I thought that I had at
least bought the most figures
in the store
because I saw Joey's whole
and I was like, I got this one.
I didn't realize how
many figures you bought.
- Yeah. You're watching
my next figure then?.
- Sure.
- [Joey] Oh yes. Let's go.
Rohan Kishibe.
- Kishibe Rohan.
- 17 bucks.
- [Joey] What?
- [Joey] And that face is not bad.
- That's a damn...
No that is like one of the
more accurate JoJo figures
that I've seen.
- For Araki's figure as well.
- Yeah. That is a nice figure.
- Dude look at that like swaying head.
- Yeah dude, look at this boy, 17 bucks.
- That's a good fucking deal.
I can't get this fucking head on that.
- Hold on, give it.
- We can get it to work.
- His head just does not want to come on
- I have three more
- [Joey] Three more!
- Oh my God.
Give, give me the next one.
I'll start unpacking it for you.
Yeah, Under the table.
So I'm not gonna look at what it is
I'm just going to start unpacking it.
- Oh my God how the fuck do you do this.
- I know, right? It's so hard.
Okay. Go for it.
- We should give it to our producer.
Meilyne to, to put together. Right?
Meilyne, would you like to put
together the figure for us?
- [Meilyne] Yeah.
- Yeah, go on.
Give it, give it to Meilyne.
- Thanks Meilyne.
- Help me Meilyne.
- All right.
So my next figure, if you will.
- [Joey] Oh yes I saw that one.
- That was the Levi
one you were eyeing up.
- Levi, sitting on a couch
just doing Levi things
like I just thought--
- [Joey] Like what's he holding?
- Like a handkerchief.
- [Joey] Oh, okay. Yeah.
- Just Levi's sitting on a couch.
I thought it would look
so like nice on the set
and also it's best boy Levi, like.
- [Joey] Of course
- Look at it.
It's a beautiful figure.
- Yeah. That's actually
really nice like small--
- It's an expensive figure though.
I'm not gonna lie.
- Really?
- How much was it?
70 bucks.
- Whoa!
But I had to cause like,
it's Levi sitting down.
I mean, come on you guys.
(laughing)
- So was that the most expensive figure
you boy at Astop then?
- At Astop, yes.
- Okay.
- But not overall.
- Not overall.
- Okay. I don't think it
matters because there's this.
(laughs)
- Yeah
- I didn't get to that.
- I think I've won.
- I got close to that
but you know.
So that's, Levi's sitting on it.
I just think it's so cute.
I don't know why. It's just that I feel--
- I love it when figurines
have like interesting bases.
- Yeah.
- Like it just makes it
seem so much more alive.
I love it.
All right. We're still going with Connor,
there's more.
- Connor and I
it's just like giving him
a handjob under the table.
That's like it's just, go break it.
(laughs)
- Next up.
- Boys and boys.
- Boy, My God Gendo, Jesus.
- Dude that's cool!
- That's cool.
- How much do you think this is worth?
- I wanna say $15.
- Yeah.
- Five bucks.
- What! Are you serious?
- Did you guys not see this?
- No because like I said the thing about--
- [Connor] Oh, that is sexy.
Yeah so that's a bundle with that
so that goes next to it..
- Yeah, we've got the
whole Slime bundle there.
- Oh yeah we do. Oh yeah shit!
- I got this for five bucks.
I thought you never see like, I love it
when they make figures of
characters that aren't the mains.
- Yeah.
- Because they're always like
really rare, they're
normally super expensive
but the fact that this was 5 bucks
I just think that's awesome.
- Because they were like
1,000,000,000 Asuka figures
1,000,000,000 Rei figures
- Oh my God. Every single,
like Evangelion like robot.
- Yeah, exactly.
Is this the last one.
- It is indeed.
- Man, you are like--
- I think I might've won the most figures.
- I think you might have.
- I think he might have.
- You might have won single handedly
with just this store.
- No I think you've bought
more figures in this store
than I have overall.
- Yeah, I think so too.
- Okay don't look.
- Okay I won't look.
(laughs)
I should've gone more ham at Astop.
- Because I was surprised
with deals at Astop.
- There was deals at Astop.
Are you ready boys?
- Yeah.
- For the last figure,
let me get these out of the way
I feel like they may be having a....
This is my last figure.
- Ooh, Eren.
- It comes with a little
swords you can put in.
I just thought it was a cool figure.
I think it was like 30, 40 bucks.
I mean, you guys wanna
have a look at that?
- Yeah.
- That was my final figure at Astop.
I think I got quite the fucking whole.
- I think you did.
- You did.
- Jesus Christ!
I mean, I just can't get
over this Rias figurine.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
That is some, one of the nicest figures.
I was eyeing this.
- [Garnt] Isn't it.
- And I'm just like do
I commit to the podcast
or do I just buy this for myself?
- No, that figure fucked me
over for the rest of the day.
But you know what?
It was worth damn it.
It was worth it.
That was like--
- Look now, from now on after this episode
you get to fucking stare
at this beautiful thing in the background
every single thing.
- Why are we getting
demonetized every
episode? We've got this--
- Is it because of a Rias' bare
like dump truck ass right here.
(laughs)
- Jesus Christ.
Demonetization, what was that?
- So with that giant whole ass away...
My God!
So let's go with the third--
- Wait, how much did you spend at Astop?
I mean spent less than $100 at Astop.
My most expensive thing was
the Jump thing right here
which was 50 bucks.
- That's cool a shit though.
- [Joey] It is cool a shit.
- I spent 220 bucks.
- Oh my God, shit.
I need to check how much exactly I spent--
- Because one of the challenges
was whoever spends the most
at a single store gets a point.
- What was...
Actually, we can figure
that out ourselves.
I also spent 220 bucks at Astop.
- Oh!
- It's going to go down
to the tiny numerals next.
But the third store we
went to was K-Books.
K-Books, much like a lot of stores
in the large of Kaikan building.
They sell figurines
but they also sell a
bunch of like other merch
like figurines, plushies,
just little knickknacks
and stuff like that so.
- [Garnt] I don't remember...
Oh no I do remember exactly what I bought.
I bought two things.
- Okay. So let's talk
about strategy first.
So what was your guys'
strategy going into K-Books
- This is the point where
I started considering
how much money I have left.
Like Astop it was like spend spend.
Because I felt like I was
too behind at Animate.
So I went ham in Astop
and then this is when I was like,
okay maybe I should start
like being careful when I buy.
- Oh no, I was the complete opposite.
At this point I had more
than half of my budget left.
- [Garnt] Oh my God
- Oh shit I get.
- So I was going to go like
big bucks boy on K-Books
and the final Amiami store.
- So what did you buy?
- So I got two.
So one of my challenges
was to get an Astolfo figurine.
I don't know why super specificly
but luckily I found one Astolfo figurine.
Didn't even come in box.
- This motherfucker.
- Oh Goddamnit!
Because what happened right? Was--
- There was two.
He just hit the one that you didn't find.
- Because we were walking past it
and I saw the Astolfo figure
and I was just like putting
loads of other figures
on top of that.
(laughing)
So I was like, Connor, look at this
and I didn't see the second one so.
- Yeah there was another
one like right near it.
- So I like waited ahead
and I watched him as
he was going through it
and he actually found another one.
But the one that you
buried, he didn't find.
- Yeah, I didn't know.
This is the only one I've
found and I'm like, thank God.
- Oh dammnit.
- Because he always got
me with that conspiracy.
But then the second one I got...
Oh the second challenge was
to find a Cardcaptor Sukara figurine.
Unfortunately I couldn't find one
but I know that if I went to K-Books
like six months ago, like the new Sukara
was still like hot and
fresh in everyone's minds.
I knew I would have found one
but, so I gave up on that.
So instead I spent big boy dollars
and got this really cool
Yuojo Senki figurine.
- [Garnt] That's so cool.
I'm like, I'm not a huge
fan of Tanya personally
but this is a fucking cool figurine.
- That's an awesome figurine.
- How much was that?
This was $132.
- Ooh okay.
- With an interchangeable head though.
(laughing)
Great! Can't wait to
change the heads every day.
- Every episode we changing the head.
- Oh my God. Don't say that,
we'll have to do it.
(laughing)
- We're gonna have to come here.
But that's pretty much the
only two things I bought.
- Yeah. Because at this point
I was just trying to stay alive.
Astop really fucked me over.
- Oh way yeah, because
spent how much at Astop
And then you also spent
a shit ton at Animate.
- Yeah. So I think I budgeted it.
It's like, I think I could
only spend around 70 bucks
or something or maybe less in each store.
So I had to complete the challenges.
So the first challenge
was just getting a figure
from a Shonen series.
(laughs)
- Another Mike I can't take it.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, I already knew
I'd lost at this point.
So I didn't really...
But what surprised me
because I wasn't really
familiar with a K-Books
so I didn't know what kind
of merchandise they had.
They did not have a lot of Shonen figures.
- No
- That's all.
- Right? It was between
this one and a Luffy one
and I just went for the cheapest
one because I needed to--
- You wanted the challenge done.
- I wanted the challenge done.
Second thing was to buy
something Lewd, all right.
- That was not difficult
as there was a gigantic hentai section.
There were like like Hanbok like,
I think like half of the
store was just like 18 plus.
- So I'm like, this is big Rei mode.
What lewd thing can I buy
that's really cheap and
can keep me on budget.
So I brought Dojuinshi.
(laughs)
- Oh who did you get?
- Oh my God.
- Jean Outta
- Of course.
- I just like I was more focused
on finding a cover which
wouldn't get us easily like,
which just wouldn't
get this video off the,
what am I talking about?
Demonetized or age restricted.
- That's big brain YouTuber boy.
- Yeah. But I did buy one more.
- Okay.
- But I just checked it
before we started recording.
I don't think I can share it.
- Maybe you can just show a blured picture
and we can all get a reaction to it.
- Okay.
- Yeah. maybe mood on,
just put like a huge black screen
over whatever Garnt brings out.
So I bought a Dakimakura.
(laughs)
- A what?
- Wow, where are we gonna
put that?
- I thought we could just
hang it up on the wall.
That was like the intent.
We're not going to be able to use this.
- Okay.
- Because I was like I
need to buy a Dakimakura.
- ''I need to buy a Dakimakura!''
- Yes I do.
- Right. What did you get?
- So I bought the
cheapest one I could find.
And like it was in the
section there weren't many
like the Dakimakuras weren't all lewd.
You know, there was some lewds,
there was some one
and they were all like covered up.
- Where are you going with this?
- So I couldn't tell how Lewd
the Dakimakuras were I just
chose the cheapest one.
- Oh Jesus.
- Oh wow. Oh no.
- We're not going to be able to use this.
- Black all of that out.
- They sell that?
- Yes.
- This wasn't, this wasn't
even in the hentai section.
- Okay. Can I ask?
Because he got the cheapest one.
How much was that?
- 40 bucks.
- What! 40 bucks
- That's the cheapest one?
- Yeah that's the cheapest one.
Right I bought Like a sens one at home
that was Akatena.
Don't ask me why.
So my two challenges were
buy JoJo figure and do the pose.
And I was really lucky
that there was any one JoJo figure
which I'll show you shortly.
The other one was Buy a Wall Scroll.
Now there was a bunch
of cheap wall scrolls
like 400, 500
but I thought I should
probably get one from a show
that I actually like liked.
So I spent 10 bucks on Katanagatari.
- [Joey] Oh, hell yeah.
- My God.
I love, Katanagatari is
one of my favorite shows.
- [Joey] It's so good.
- It's totally underrated, not underrated.
- So many people haven't seen it as well.
- Everyone who has seen the
show says it's fucking amazing.
- Yeah it is.
- And if you haven't seen it, it's like--
- It's Nishio Ishin of
course it's gonna be good.
- It's like a Quentin Tarantino anime
I feel like it's so fucking good.
- People who haven't seen it
are just like, which season
of Monogatari is this?
(all laugh heartedly)
It's nothing to do with
the Monogatari series.
- It's amazing. Please watch it.
And I mean she's Waifu material.
- Yeah definitely.
- So that was 10 bucks I mean.
- Yeah that's bringing me
back memories up constantly
- I know when I've been
to this show.
- Makes me wanna
watch it again.
- I don't know where
we're going to put this.
I'll just put right it here.
Also I got a JoJo figure.
- Of course.
- Which one though?
- Which one?
- Because I remember
when you got the challenge and you were
like, buy a JoJo figure.
I was like, this motherfucker.
You got so lucky with the challenges.
- I did.
- The only reason
why you got four points
is because all of them
was so easy for you.
- Except okay.
And the last door, we
shall talk about that.
That was a little annoying somehow.
But yeah, so I got the Giorno
Giovanna Golden Experience.
- Ooh!
- It's actually like it's,
okay I'm not gonna lie,
His face doesn't look
like 10 out of 10 on it
but that's what you get with JoJo figures.
But at least we got another JoJo figure.
- Oh nice.
So I'm the one who did all the hard work.
- So what's that, three now?
It's Rohan, Giorno and Diamond.
- This was 66 bucks though.
And that's like--
- Can I see that?
- Yeah. And to be honest with you
66 bucks is kind of like cheap
for JoJo figure normally.
- Yeah.
- The more I look at this face
the more hilarious it gets.
Just like look into his face.
- It's kinda how I would say.
- It' kinda funny.
- We'll take a picture of this
and show it on the podcast.
- It's not how I would
describe as manga accurate
but it's, I mean, more like Kendall,
but whatever I'm not gonna (indistinct).
That's all I bought at K-Books.
I was just doing my challenges.
- Okay so we each bought two things each?
- Oh no, I bought three.
I mean, I was just like--
- I just wanted to get my challenges done.
- I got my challenges done
and I was like I'm just on the mission
to demonetize this channel.
(laughs)
That was my mission.
- Don't worry you will do that naturally.
- I was worrying because
like I went into K-Books
and I mean I was thinking like
I'm gonna buy a $200 figure.
- Yeah.
- K-Books quickly ruined that plan
because of the challenges.
So I spent 77 bucks on just my challenge.
And then obviously I
realized when I got to Amiami
which we're gonna do right now
I had challenges that I had to do as well.
- Yeah.
- So we should talk about Amiami.
- [Joey] Okay, so let's talk about Amiami.
- So for me, Amiami was just,
I was just trying to survive.
I was, I think I figured out
I had like I think $60 or $50.
- 60 bucks left?
- [Joey] What!
- Yeah.
I was just, at this point,
just praying and hoping.
Like--
- But you wasted fucking
$40 on a fucking pillowcase.
(laughing)
Like why would you do that?
- Don't judge me, okay?
- It wasn't even a part of the challenge.
- I know. I just wanted
a Dakimakura, okay?
- It's just like a guy
who like gambles all this money away
and says I just don't understand
why I got the money all
the time, man. It sucks
- Well because like, I knew this would be
my only opportunity to buy a Dakimakura.
- Of course.
- Why did you
want to buy one so badly?
- Because he's fucking part
of Trash Taste, that's why.
- Look it's called Trash
Taste for a reason.
- Fine. All right. Sue me.
We had a lot of blank space
in the background where
we could hang one up.
So I was like, Dakimakura?
I think that's a good purchase.
And now I bought one wasted $40.
Can't even use it.
Fucking brilliant.
(laughs)
- We can't even hang it up.
It's just going to be a
black box in the video.
- I've got one at my house.
I've got a pillow. The
Dakimakura pillow so.
- I mean, I've got one of
Shoujo hanging on me wall so.
But with me, for Amiami
this is where I spent
the most amount of money
because I had almost like,
I think I had like 2/3
of my budget still left
because I knew I'd been
into Amiami before,
not the one in Kaikan that we went to
but there's another one
in Akihabara as well.
- And you can spend a
lot of money in there.
- Yeah I spent a lot of money there
and I know they have
some really expensive figurines,
but they have a huge selection as well.
So I knew I was going to find
something hopefully good.
I mean that's before this Rias
showed up and ruin my plans
but my two challenges I believe was
by a plushie, a character plushie.
And the other one
I don't remember what it was.
But I got a plushie. I
actually got two plushies.
- [Connor] Okay.
- Because I needed to, you know,
spend my money and get
close to $500 as possible.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- So I got Moogle and Chocobo.
- Okay.
- Because I love Final Fantasy
and Final Fantasy Seven
remake recently just came out
and I love the fuck out of it.
- [Garnt] That's cute as fuck.
- Yeah so give out JLPG some love as well.
So I got that and the
most expensive figurine
that I got overall.
- Oh more expensive than anyone?
- Oh, okay.
- This is the most expensive overall.
- Did you buy this
purposely to like finish--
- I bought this purposely to get as close
to $500 as possible.
- Oh okay.
- So this was not part of the challenge.
I got a Tokisaki Kurumi from Date A Live.
- [Garnt] Oh nice.
- Okay.
I mean again, this is kind
of going to be like Rias
in the sense that like,
possibly demonetize.
- Oh that's hot.
- But I know Tokisaki figurines
can for some reason, so expensive.
I mean she's a really popular
Date A Live character.
- How much was it then?
- This was $141.
Not as expensive as the Rias,
I've already lost that challenge but.
- I may have overheard or
saw Joey when he was buying that one.
And I thought all I gotta do is beat 1300.
- Yeah.
And I literally just went over 1300
on a more expensive figure
which I'll reveal soon.
- Okay. Because, was that
everything you bought?
- And that's everything I bought.
- Okay. Because for me, Amiami
was a stressful experience.
Not because of the store itself.
The store itself is great,
but because I saw my challenges,
which was one, find an
Evangelion figurine.
That was a lot harder
than I initially gave it credit for.
- Really?
- Yeah. Because I missed
the entire figure section
right at the back.
So I was just walking around
and there was one figure
I found which was $200.
No, actually no way that
I could buy that figure.
And I found another
figure, which was 50 bucks.
No, 50 to 70 bucks.
But that was the tiny
little budget that I had.
- You really fucked yourself.
- Yeah. I really fucked myself.
- You hate to see it.
This girl me fucked so badly.
- Hey, I mean, she's a succubus.
( laughs)
- What can you say?
- But luckily I found an Asuka pop figure.
- Oh no! Why did you do a pop figure?
- No! Why God. Why would
you buy a pop figure man.
- Because it was the cheapest okay.
- I think this is going to be awarded
for the most normy.
(laughs)
This thing right here.
No offense, if you like pop vinyls
but we--
- No offense. If you do like Pop vinyls.
Like we say, no offense.
They're fucking ugly dude.
- I thought they'd be nice.
- I fucking hate pop figures. Oh Jesus.
How much did you spend on this?
- 14 bucks.
- Okay not bad.
- You know what it's like?
It's like, you come to Japan, right?
You have all these amazing figures.
- Yeah.
- You go for fucking
pop figures.
It's like going into like
Germany an being like
I want hotdogs, from the can please.
I want not none of that stuff.
- It's like going to
Germany and being like,
can I have an Asahi?
- Yeah. It's like, what the fuck?
- No fine. I--
- All right... I'll give
it for the challenge.
It was for the challenge,
because there're like
like this Amiami had
a lot of good figures.
That I really, really wanted to buy.
I just needed to go for the cheapest one.
And then the second one
which I had no idea how to complete was
buy a furry and like
100% non-humanoid figure.
And I was like
the only thing I could
fkn think of was Chopper
from One Piece.
Did not have any Chopper figures.
So I was like I've probably lost this.
And then I was like, wait a minute.
There's there's probably
one thing I could twist
and that's Eevee figure.
- Okay, that counts.
- I was like, okay if I
can't go the chopper route
maybe I can go to the Pokemon route.
- How the are fuck have they
spelled Eevee on this box?
- [Joey] EIEVUI.
- What's with that? Why do
they spell it like that?
- I don't know because I guess
that's how they pronounce it in Japanese
But I don't think they realize
that there's a way easy spelling of Eevee
- Yeah.
- Okay that's cute.
- Okay you know, that counts.
Because when you pulled that out
I thought you were going
to get one of these.
- Yeah, because I didn't think
those kinda does a figure, right?
But I'm like Eevee's furry
is non-humanoid figure.
Shut the fuck up I am getting that point.
- Okay.
- No okay that counts.
- Because there was between like Eevee
and Miu too and I was like Eevee's cute.
So yeah what were the
challenges that you had Connor?
- I had, buy three anime mugs or glasses
(laughs)
We painfully asked
because they were no sets or anything.
It was like they were all
like pretty expensive as well.
- Oh you had to buy them separately.
- Yeah , and then it was also
buy a figure that you think is trash.
- So wait, how much budget did
you have left at this point?
- 140 something.
- Oh, so you like balanced
it out pretty well
between the four stores?
- Yeah because I basically
spent nothing at Animate
I spent 70 bucks at K-Books.
So I kind of like did pretty
good at budgeting by accident.
I hadn't planned anything.
I think not having challenges
that fuck me over was helpful.
- Yeah that was definitely helpful.
- The figure that I thought it was trash
was just this shitty Sunrio one.
(laughs)
- I thought you were gonna
go like ironic trash, right?
- Yeah.
- No, it was like 220 Yen as well
which might be the
cheapest figure as well.
- It's is probably the cheapest figure.
- I just...
Who the is the Sanrio character.
Does anyone know it?
- Oh I think I know it.
- You know it? I know like the.
- Pochacco
- I know Tamagu one, the egg one.
- I love Tamagu.
- Gudetama?
- Yeah.
- And obviously Hello Kitty
but I don't know. What
the fuck. Okay, whatever.
And the funny mugs I bought from,
I don't know where they're from.
Do you wanna open them, I guess?
- Sure.
- That was 100 Yen luckily
But every other mug was like 1,000 Yen.
I managed to find two for 600 Yen.
So we have more mugs now
for the podcast I guess.
We'll drink from those possibly
maybe never I don't know.
- These are like tightly packed
There's the mugs.
So I did the challenges. Cool.
And then I was like so annoyed
because the there was a Froppy figure.
The one with like the
cool comic book text.
- I sold that one.
I had just enough budget to get that
if it wasn't for this shit.
(laughs)
So I had to completely change my mind.
I'm not saying this stuff is bad
but it ruined my plan, just saying.
So I had to go with a different...
I mean ,I guess you get
what you pay for, right?
That's all I'm gonna say like
it was 100 Yen for a reason you know.
- What series is this?
- I don't fucking know.
- I have no idea.
- Oh no, it's all characters on the back
which I didn't see.
- And then these are from some Otome game.
- Oh yeah they look like Otome games
- I don't watch or play any Otome games.
I know they're huge here in Japan but.
- I mean for a female demographic
- I would just prefer Yaoi.
Just straight up Yaoi.
Don't like try and--
- If you had come out with a Yaoi like mug
I think you would have one like coolest.
(laughs)
- Maybe. The final figure
and most expensive figure that I bought.
- Right, oh C.C?
- Oh C2!
- C.C, C2, whatever.
Same thing, 2C.
It's her like on the like pedestal.
- [Joey] That's cool.
That's a dump truck I've ever seen.
- Ooh.
- That's an ass.
- That's who you see in the figure.
I should get it out
so you guys can fully
appreciate this figure
but yes that was--
- How much was that?
- That was 130 bucks,
honestly worth every penny
- I guess while they're
opening these figurines up
I guess I just want to ask you guys,
like how was the challenge like overall?
Like do you have a good feeling?
- I have more stuff by the way.
- Oh, you have more stuff.
- I have more stuff.
- Okay.
- Which is probably...
- Do you want to open this while I.
- Okay.
- We should also
preface as well that
there is like consequences
for the final scores
and everything.
Basically, whoever has the
lowest score at the end
like including the points that we got
in our individual videos
as well as the points
that we're going to add up
at the end of this episode
has to do some kind of punishment
in a traditional really
sadistic Japanese way.
We're basically gonna
be consuming something
that we personally don't
really want to consume
with these two because
they're absolute pussies.
They're going to have to
eat one packet of nokdu
which is like Japanese fermented soybeans.
- It's disgusting.
- I love it.
- It smells horrible, okay?
Thank you very much I grew up with it.
So obviously I'm not going
to eat that if I lose.
I'm gonna have to eat the spicy noodles
that I ate in my JoJo quiz video
which you can go check out on my channel.
Yeah. But we're going to find that out
at the end of the episode
once we've calculated all the scores
but I guess in the meantime as well
let us know down in the
comments below so far,
what is the favorite
figurine that you sourced.
- It's my one I know it.
- Most likely it's going to be this one.
- I'm like so happy I bought that now
because I bought it on
pure instinct, right?
I wasn't trying to win the game.
I didn't have any strategy in mind.
- You were horny on maine
I was just horny on maine
and I just wanted everyone to see it.
I love as well
how the base is like buried
so you can like walk up at it.
- Damn! That's a good figure.
- Damn that is a beautiful.
- [Joey] Ooh, look at that butt dude.
Look at that competition man.
(laughs)
- Just saying so
- Who has the bigger
dump truck.
- Yeah.
- Now I know Garnt
is gonna shit himself now
but the rest of my purchases
were to get that even 500 bucks.
- Okay.
- So I just bought like a fucking.
I don't even know what this is.
- What is that?
It goes on a doorknob
I think, or something.
I don't really know.
- It's like an arrow-man.
Let me open this.
- A towel of some.
- Of Ani Tore.
- It was 100 Yen. A towel.
- What is this show?
- That's the POV anime
where like the cute girls like workout.
- Yeah oh shit. I remember.
- It's so bad. I love it.
- I got some scroll from some shirts.
- Wow, you've really like
weighed like cold stuff overall.
- Did someone have like a challenge
where you have to buy a wall scroll?
- It was from a different...
- Oh yeah.
- Trading cards for 210 Yen.
(laughs)
- Like what trading cards?
- What is this?
Oh, wait, you can put something in here.
- It's probably for like tickets maybe,
something like that.
Train tickets, maybe concert tickets.
It's you know, if you want like to know
who is a weaboo you just put this on them.
- It's like a tracking, you know.
That's everything that I bought
and it came out to an even 500 exactly.
- Oh, are you serious?
- Bang on 500.
- Oh fuck!
- I did this footage in my video
which you guys should see.
I went to the cashier
and I went 10 Yen over.
So I asked the guy, I'm like,
no take all this stuff out
I'm going back.
( Joey and Garnt laugh)
And they were all so confused
they were like, ''what's
he trying to say?''
I'm like, get rid of the
stuff I got to go back.
So I went and found exactly what it was.
Did the math on the spot
went through my camera footage
to find out what I spent at each store.
- Oh my God.
- Until exactly 500 bucks.
- I was like, I don't think there's anyone
that's going to get close
to $500, like at all.
So I was like if I can get
as close as I can to 500
then I think I probably won.
So I think my overall
price came to 49,840 Yen.
So I was 160 Yen off.
- Wow.
- Because for me, I was, after Astop
I had just stopped
calculating stuff and that.
(laughs)
- You had given up.
- Like I was like, I'm
probably going to go bust.
I'm probably going to go bust
and lose the entire thing.
But no, mine actually
came out to 47,152 Yen.
- Oh, we all got really close.
- Which is like $470.
That's how...
We should probably explain
that we are calculating it by dollars
by just dividing by 100 from the--.
- Yeah, because that's roughly what it is.
- Yeah.
- So I guess
for the first challenge of
can get closest to $500,
those two points are
going to go to Connor.
- Hell yes, that means
I'm in the lead now.
- Holy fuck those two points.
- Damn I was so confident that I was like,
I thought like old both of you
were get to get like kind of what I got
so I'm like, no dude, I'm 160 Yen away.
I got this.
- Joey seemed so confident
when we were filming
that I thought he must have done
the exact same thing as
me and got like exact.
- [Joey] No!
- No because this fucker, he was like,
I thought he'd planned everything, right?
- Same .
- I talked to him off screen--
- He turned up smiling and everything.
- And I'm like, he's like,
I got my strategy for each store
and I'm like, I have got none.
- I did not.
(laughing)
- No, I was just bluffing you guys.
Obviously like a good game of poker
You've gotta be overconfident.
- Whatever, you bluffed me
into being exact with my money.
I wouldn't have done that if I didn't know
that you might've been exact.
- Goddammnit! Because I didn't think
you were going to like
buy all this small shit
to like get exact.
- I wanted to get those two points.
I don't want to eat fucking nokdu Joey.
- Nor do I.
- Okay, well then, that was huge.
So let's go over the next
couple of challenges.
I think there's 10 left.
- Yeah.
- 10 left.
- So the second one is
the most expensive figure.
- Obviously that goes to Garnt
and this does all that.
- That was 160?
- 16700 Yen.
- Wow so 170 bucks basically.
And yours was 140?
- Mine was 141.
- And the mine was 137.
So Garnt gets to the
point for that I guess.
- Yeah.
- Next one is the cheapest figurine
I got that 220 Yen figure.
- Yeah.
- Did anyone beat that?
- No mine was Puck, which is 980.
- Yeah.
- Ooh. Mine was, I think I
can't even fucking remember.
It was 1,000 bucks, I noted it down.
- 1,000 bucks!
- No, it was 1,000 Yen.
- So even even if I didn't buy that
I still had the Evangelion.
- Yeah you still would have won with--
- So yeah, you still would have won
even if it was anime figure.
- So, okay, damn,
I feel pretty good right now, all right.
- Okay.The lowest rated series on MAL
- Okay, you wanna go first?
- Which one is yours.
- What's my number? It
was like Otome brave
which I think is that Mug
and it was like 2,375.
- Oh damn!
- Okay what's yours.
- Mine was (laughs), Rias.
- Really! That's the lowest?
- Oh my God
- Yeah, it was like
1,744 on MAL.
- Okay. Well, give me the point
because mine wasn't
Berserk, which is 5,687.
- No way, no.
- Because it's the anime not the manga.
Hell yeah.
- What the hell. Goddamn.
- It's the garbage anime
not the manga.
I'm sure if I looked at
what that fucking towel was
the scores might be a little different.
(laughing)
I don't fucking know what it is.
So I guess that's not fair.
- Point to me baby. Let's go.
- Yeah. So the next was
the most figures bought.
- In one store.
- No overall. Did we do store and?
- No we just did overall.
- Okay, well, I only bought seven.
- I have 14.
- 10.
- I mean, I think you bought
some more figures in Astop.
- I filled up the thing
and I bought everything
that I filled up in those--
- You bought more figurines at Astop
than I did overall.
- And I'm not gonna lie, right
you have a good selection
but I think my selection is
pretty fucking strong as well.
- Oh yeah, no, all three of our selections
are really strong
- Yeah.
- I don't know about Garnt.
I mean this figure is great but the rest.
Look at, his selection is strong?
Get out of here Garnt.
- Okay, next one.
Most spent on one series.
All of mine were separate
so I'm just going to go off the base
that this is(masked over by Connor)
- I totally forgot about this one.
- Yeah.
- Wait, what could it be?
- It's probably JoJo, right?
- Wait it could have been JoJo
but it wouldn't have been...
I spent a lot on like
Attack on Titan and JoJo
but I didn't get anything
near 160 overall.
(laughs)
- She's just solo carrying
these challenges for me now.
- What was the thing, right?
Is that we may challenges
that we'll reward you
for being frugal with your money
and buying little things
but also would reward you if you bought,
if you did the gamble
that paid off the most,
- Yeah, that's the gamble.
- Because you had to guess, right?
Because I was thinking in my head,
would Joey buy a $200 figure?
I think he could.
- I was going to.
- I thought both of you couldn't
and I was like, maybe I should just give
up on that challenge, right?
And just focus on everything else.
- Fuck.
- Yeah because like,
when I saw her, I was like,
I just want to buy her
because she was like a
really unique figure.
I saw tits and I thought I'd just.
I saw titties and I didn't think
and before I knew it I was
writing down the number.
- His wife was right there as well
but it didn't matter.
- It was funny because out
of every figure I bought
this one was the one that I
didn't think about the most.
I was like, I'm getting this figure.
I'm not even going to think about it.
- [Joey] My god.
The most spent on a non-figure.
- Oh for me it would be
I guess the squashy, which is 2,800 Yen.
- Mine was 1,100.
- Okay. Mine was a Dakimakura.
- Shit he spent 40 bucks on it.
(laughs)
I guess it paid off.
- [Joey] Fuck!
- If being at degenerates
fucking saved me in this game
I'm so fucking happy.
- [Joey] Goddamnit.
- Okay. All right.
What's the next.
- Next one is most spent in one store.
- Okay how much did you
spend exactly in Astop.
- I spent $197.
- What did you spend?
- 22,380 Yen.
- Fuck I spent 22,190.
- Oh, come on.
- Okay. Here we go.
Closest to 69 (laughs) closest to $69.
This was the meme one.
- I don't know at all about this one.
For me it was the Shonen Jump thing
which was 4,980 Yen.
- Okay. Mine was mine
was the Edward Elric one.
- Yeah
- Which was 5,299.
- All right, I win $66 baby.
on the Giorno Giovanna one funny enough.
- Oh shit.
- So the one that I had no choice to buy
got me another point so, sweet.
- Oh my God I'm gonna fucking lose.
Okay, normy awards
so whoever has my highest
rank on Mal loses the point.
- I think I lose this, right?
- What did you get?
- Attack on Titan.
- Is that higher than Fullmetal Alchemist.
- Attack on Titan is number two I think
if I looked correctly.
- Ooh I thought I lost.
- Number one is Death Note.
- Okay I'm definitely saved
because mine was
the Monogatari which is 56
- Yeah, most popular
according to myanime list
is Death Note, Shingeki
no Kyojin SoldaT online
then Fullmetal Alchemist by the way.
- How did I not lose that one.
Because I saw by boy Levi.
Where is he? ,.Where is it?
Look at how beautiful he
is, okay, I could not.
- Oh my God.
- So I lose a point.
So Connor loses a point.
- Okay. Final one,
buying a hentai figure.
Okay, So I--
- I mean that's zero points for me, baby.
- I'm gonna argue this.
- No.
- Okay here's why.
I didn't realize this
but you can replace Rias's
tits to be uncensored.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah. I didn't know what that was
until I opened it up.
Those are just nipples.
(laughs)
I didn't know,
they came with interchangeable nipples.
- Oh my God. Wait, how
do you take those off?
It's not the thing that--
- We're going to find that out
after the, yeah.
- So I think
- Oh, so they're
attached to the head.
Oh my God.
- I mean I would like to argue
that you bind the
Dakimakura already counts
as like a hentai thing.
- But that wasn't a figure
but I think that uncensored nipples
counts as a hentai figure
because we can't show it--
Oh, but is it though?
Cause it's High School DxD.
It's not technically hentai.
- I mean--
- If there's tits out though
is it a hentai figure.
- I mean, I would like to argue that
if it's something we
can't show on this podcast
then I think it counts.
- Of which I have two now.
- Yeah exactly fucking degenerate grading.
- Then I think I get a point.
- Okay, we'll give Garnt the point
This isn't a hentai figure so.
- No that's just a cultural figure.
- Man I'm so fucking glad
I bought this figure now.
- Dude, this single figurine
clutched you the victory like.
Oh my God.
Okay. And the total scores were
Connor with 12 points,
Garnt with 12 points
and I got seven points.
- I would have won this
if I didn't buy the Attack
on Titan figures by the way.
- I would have won this
if I was actually smart.
- I probably would have lost this
if I didn't buy this one single figure.
- So it was also your downfall
but it also got you all
the points in all this.
- It got you more positives
than negatives this thing.
- Because, God, when we were like
going through all these challenges
because we had completely
forgotten the overall challenges
and I was like, wait a minute.
I think this one figure could
be a lot of these challenges.
I'm like.
- I totally forgot we put
hentai figure in there.
I would have bought a
shitty one if I remembered
- Because like, it would
have been hard because--
- There's not many hentai figures.
- No ,because all of the hentai figures
were like 100s of dollars.
They're very expensive.
- Yeah they normally are,
I mean, you know
it's a very cultured island--
- I just like to point out
that over all of these
like overall challenges
I only got a 1 point.
(laughing)
- You hate to see it.
- And that was the fact
that Puck is the lowest
rated out of everything here.
- I think the thing is, right?
Is that he went all out with that,
I was a bit more conservative,
spread my money out you know.
And then you kind of.
- I just bought shit that I like.
- You went mid-range.
You were like I'll keep buying
kind of expensive things
but not really.
- I was just like, I like this shit,
I'll just buy it.
- This is what happens
when you try to strategize and just.
(laughs).
- I will at least like the credit
of probably getting the coolest one.
- [Garnt] No.
- That's cool.
- [Garnt] You can have that point Joey.
- Yeah. I'll have that point.
- You can have that fake point
- I'm still not going to win.
I'll take the pity points, fuck you.
- I fucking love this figure.
This is such a nice figure, holy shit.
- Well, since I lost I guess
I have to eat a horrible thing.
I think our producer
Meilyne brought something
which I am not looking forward to eating.
- Well that already.
I can't even smell it
but I can picture what it smells like.
- [Meilyne] I've opened it.
- Thank you Meilyne
our amazing producer.
- All right. Well my
challenge has arrived.
Hey, it's Tai.
(laughs)
- So what is this?
- It's pickled mud fish.
- So apparently according to our producer
this smells awful--
- And apparently is just as bad
if not worse than a surstromming
which is like pickled
I think it's like merkel or something.
It's like Swedish thing
that all YouTubers eat.
- Okay. Do you want, you wanna open it up
and give it a smell there Joey?
- Yeah, I'll give it a sniff.
- What's it kinda like.
Oh my God I just saw
that man go to heaven.
I saw that man go to heaven.
- That smells like actual like poop.
- You went to heaven there.
- Smell it.
- I can smell it
from here man.
- Smell it, like put his nose in it.
(grunts)
(laughing)
- Oh what the fuck.
- This looks really bad.
- [Joey] It looks and smells poop.
- It's like vomit, bro.
You're not going to be
able to beat that down.
- I've smelled this before.
(laughing)
- Of course you have, it's Tai
- Oh jeez it's fucking
stinking up the office.
Fucking eat it quick
- Okay. I mean we have no utensils
so I'm just gonna have to get in there.
- Can you eat that?
- I think I've eaten that.
- Oh my God.
- You have eaten it?
- Yeah. It's like really
salted fish, right?
So it's going to be super salty.
- Oh God, what the fuck!
- I'm just going to
grab like a piece of it
if you don't mind.
- Oh my God, wait, just
show it on camera show.
Show that piece on camera.
(laughing)
- Oh Jesus Christ.
Garnt are we gonna sensor that?
Like Jesus!
- Oh my God.
It's smells from here.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Careful with the bugs.
- Is that enough?
- Just don't get on the microphone please.
- Bon a petite.
(soft electric music)
- [Garnt] How is it?
- Tastes like I'm eating dirt.
(laughing)
Oh God that's (grunts)
That's so salty.
- It's just salted fish, right?
It's so salty.
- Oh my God.
I don't know why I'm leaking my fingers.
(laughing heartedly)
- Ooh, get me some more of that.
- Get this man some water.
- Oh,it's getting worse.
- Because what kills you
is the fucking after taste.
The first few bites aren't that bad
but the more you chew it
the more like the flavors come out
and then the after taste just it hits you
and your breath is gonna
stink for like a fucking week.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
I got it down.
- All right. Well done.
Oh my God this fucking stinks now like--
- Hey guys.
(Garnt laughing)
How are you.
- You should wash it down with the durian.
I think that would be a good idea.
The thing is you did lose
pretty badly on this thing.
- Oh I can still smell it.
Maybe your durian will help.
(Joey coughs)
- Do you wanna smell my finger?
- No.
(laughs)
Sticky fingers.
- Oh stinky fingers more like it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
- Stinky oh oh.
- Oh my God, it's actually getting worse.
- Oh that smells viral.
I can still smell it what the fuck.
I don't think,
like I have eaten a lot
of weird foods in my life.
This is easily the grossest
thing I've ever had.
- Yeah.
I feel sorry for you Joey.
- Do you smell it over there?
Oh Jesus it's concentrated
it's like a fucking--
- I think the smell is getting stronger.
- Yeah we're in the fallout zone
here like, my God!
- It's like a nuclear blast.
- I'm like fine if I hold my nose
because like, I don't like smell the thing
but the moment I get it out,
oh, I could smell my own breath
and it's fucking viral.
- Next time next week
when we do the podcast
Joey we'll still be smelling it.
- Well I really just hope
this doesn't give me like an illness
because we're like going
on a trip tomorrow.
- Offending all Tai people right now.
(laughing)
I mean like I hope I don't
get like food poisoning
because like, we're going
on a vacation tomorrow.
- Yeah
- And I don't want to be sick.
Oh God, this mic is gonna fucking stink
I'm sorry.
- It's awful.
- We're gonna have to
like spray this mic here.
- We can open the windows
when we finish this episode, like Jesus.
(Joey exhales deeply)
- So now that the challenge is over
what are you guys' closing thoughts?
- I'm glad I didn't literal eat shit.
(Garnt laughs heartedly)
I mean, you know, the ultimate goal was;
to one, not lose and become like this man
who's going through like
the five stages of grief
with his face.
- I'm definitely at the last stage.
(laughs)
- Yeah, we got to decorate the office.
I think by a miracle
we got like some pretty good variation.
Like I honestly would love
to do something like this again in future
with another challenge where
we can each go and film
our own parts--
- I'm surprised that out of
all the things that we bought
not a single person bought the same thing.
- Yeah. Because that was the thing
I was most worried about, right?
When I, you know, pitched the challenge
the thing I was worried about was like
what if we all just go for
the same fucking figures.
- 10 Dekus, I would like
three of your finest Dekus.
(laughing)
- Because yeah, I had a lot of fun
filming in the stores
and I would love to do
something like this again.
I don't know if you guys
enjoyed seeing the aftermath
of all our different individual challenges
and how we like approached
it and everything.
- Yeah, I mean, I think it's street rolls.
I think we had fun with
every step of this process.
So I really hope that was
reflected in the video.
- I got to ask you though?
- Yeah.
- Because this is
your first time doing like a video filming
in public you know.
- Okay.
- I'm used
to embarrassing myself in public.
Like how was it? I got to know
- It was hard.
It was so hard.
- [Joey] We saw you
struggling at the beginning.
- Like I was out of Animate
when I was filming my intro.
I don't even know if you're gonna see that
because I'm I'm thinking about filming
like a separate intro anyway.
But I was just like
tripping over my words.
I had no idea.
Like give me a script, great.
I can read off the script.
If I just have to talk
about my thoughts without any scripts.
And like, a podcast is
different in my mind
because I have people to bounce off.
- Right.
Because when I'm looking at a camera
I'm like, Hey guys, there, I'm
here outside of an Animate,
and I'm like, Oh shit man.
- It's like someone
trying to speak English
for the first time.
(laughs)
- It's definitely a
skill you learn I think.
- Yeah I mean I was awkward as fuck
I remember the first time I filmed.
And I hated it. Yeah.
- But I think I got used to it
when I just, hit Astop.
Animates, I was still like
getting my feet on the ground.
With Astop I was just, I think it was
thanks to just the place as well
because I wasn't thinking about
what challenges there were
I was just thinking
about getting as many
fucking figures as I could.
- I did, I got a lot.
- Yeah you certainly fulfilled that.
- Yeah it was a lot of fun
I think as well like a great environment
like when you get permission
to film in a place
and you just go wild.
- Yeah absolutely
because the original plan for this video
was just to like MacGyver our way through.
- Go pro or underover.
- Under the chin guards.
- Yeah.
- That would have not been that great.
- Yeah. But I mean, I
haven't edited the video yet
but I think it's going to
be pretty entertaining.
And you guys can let us know as well
like, how you guys found those videos
how you found this episode.
Hopefully you guys enjoyed
watching me eat literal shit on camera.
This is easily the worst
fucking thing I've ever had.
I can still fucking taste it.
I really want you guys to smell my finger.
- No, I'm not smelling your finger Joey
- Please.
- No!
- Can you do it at least for the podcast.
- No. Come on, I smelled that shit.
- Get that shit away from me!
(exhales loudly)
- I mean, I definitely
even though this was it like a
logistical nightmare planning
speaking about logistics from episode one,
this was like an actual
logistical nightmare planning
all day.
So we had to like bounce stores
and it was short notice and everything.
Like, I would definitely
be up for doing something
where it's like three angles again
and it's a challenge that
we conclude on the podcast.
- Yeah.
- Because like,
I'm not sure if you've seen the video
but by the time we got to Amiami
I was exhausted.
Like, it was kind of like that feeling
when you've just spent an
entire day at a con working
and you're like I've got
to do one more panel.
- It was just a con in general.
- Yeah
- And fuck it, Oh we've
got to have dinner?
Oh shit I wanna sleep.
(laughs)
Like I remember post-filming
I just went home and collapsed.
- Yeah, same.
- I didn't leave my bed.
- I think we walked like
10 kilometers that day.
I checked my like, stamps.
- Typical Tokyo day.
- True.
- You've done a lot of walking
when you come to Japan?
- Yeah but I think--
- Okay, so what was the favorite
thing you guys bought then?
- That's a good question.
- Easy for you.
- Instinctively I want
to say like, I mean yeah.
- That's a good fucking figure.
- It's a solid figure
but I think the most interesting figure
and like coolest one
that I'm glad I bought
was maybe the Akira one.
which I thought was just so fun,
or the Levi one.
Mike Wazowski though.
(laughs)
That's such a good figure.
- Like all ironicly that's a good figure.
- That's fucking good figure.
- Yeah
- And also the 500,
I've forgot the name of the
character for Shinley's dad.
- Gendo
- Gendo figure, fine yeah.
- That's a good deal.
- I think my favorite
was definitely the Jump.
- Oh that's so sick.
- Because it's so unique.
- I love unique figures
because they have so many
figures that look alike.
- And who doesn't like Jump.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- That it's just going to look good.
Okay what's the worst figure you think
each of us bought.
- The worst figure?
- Yeah. I'm gonna have to agree.
- This thing, what the hell?
(joey laughs)
- I don't know actually,
I liked all the figurines I bought.
Maybe that's why it lost.
(laughs)
- What's the worst figurine
you think I bought?
- The worst one you bought?
- I mean, you bought so
many I can't remember.
- That's pretty bad.
- It's probably that one.
- You've not gotten the monogatari one.
That's kinda--
- Excuse you.
That's kinda Trash Taste if I do say so.
- Do you want to smell my finger.
(Garnt laughing heartedly)
- Smell my finger.
I have a registered weapon now right here.
(all laughing)
- Yeah and there's not much to say really.
I feel like we've
adequately roasted each other's purchases.
- And I guess I wanted to give a shout out
to all the stores we visited.
- Oh Yeah
- Absolutely.
- Because, okay, so disclaimer,
we might've shit on like
some of the things we bought
but the stores were fucking great.
- Yeah really competent as well.
- It's like, if we showed on those figure
this isn't representative to
what they had at the store.
Yeah, because some of them were just
we needed to buy stuff just
to fulfill the challenge.
I wish I could have bought something
but a pop figure for Asuka.
(all laugh)
The Amiami has so many good figures, okay?
The Amiami have so many good figures
but I had to settle for this.
- Yeah. All the stores were fantastic
and again, like thank you guys
for like giving us permission
on such short notice as well
because we're a bunch
of really loud YouTubers
as you can tell.
- Yeah. And all of the stores
were right next to each other as well
so if you go, there's no reason
not to go like all of them.
- Yes. They were all like what,
Less than 10 minutes walking
distance from one another.
- Yeah exactly.
- Garnt sorry I duped you.
- I've completely forgotten
(laughs)
- Put a spotlight on, you know
- No, I was just going to say,
yeah just thank you
for letting us film there for this show.
- The links down below.
Yeah. And I hope you
guys enjoyed this video
and the main videos.
Again, if you haven't checked out
each one of our videos where we,
you'll see, you know,
all of our perspectives
of how we came to buy
all this amazing goods,
then again go to the links
down the description below.
You can check out all three of our videos
and yeah, I guess look
out for all of this stuff
somewhere right here.
- Were you going to shout out the patreon?
- Yeah I was gonna shout out the patreon.
- Okay go ahead.
- We also have a patreon now.
This is a very expensive podcast for us.
- We spent a lot on Tokyo.
This isn't where the money went.
Okay, we did this challenge
because we wanted to do the challenge.
We need just the patreon to
keep the podcast running.
Yeah. And that's pretty much it.
- I mean, as you can tell
the editing is, you know,
is some damn good editing.
- Shout out to Mudan.
- Yeah Mudan's pretty good
We want to keep hiring him
and we want to just keep this all running.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Keep it at the best
quality that it possibly can.
And y'all guys are support
over on the patreon
is going to help us a lot.
- Perfect. All right, I have
no more words to say boys
- That's pretty much it
- I can't say anything else.
- And then Joey get the fuck away from me
with that dirty ass finger of yours.
- I'm gonna harass you
for the rest of the time with this finger.
- Can I do the outro
because I don't want you speaking anymore
than you two need to.
- Can I say one thing
before you do the outro?
- All right.
- It's a callback to previous episode
I imagine that's what
Joey's finger smelled like
after he rated School Days a 10.
(garnt laughs)
I'm not over that.
- Hey guys, before we sign off
I just wanted to give a quick
shout out to today's sponsors.
Now this is a very long name
so I'm going to have to read it out.
It's sponsored by Animationism,
a project by Japan Media Arts
Festivals Oversea Promotion
initiated by the Agency for
Cultural Affairs of Japan.
Man, that was a mouthful.
- That's a serious mouthful if you ask.
But if you guys don't know what they are
they have a lot of interviews
with Japanese creators
and also with a lot of
Japanese Anime studios as well
and a whole lot more.
- Anyway, they're having
a free anime screening
this weekend online
which you can check out
in the description below.
- So for those of you who want to know
the name of the three anime films
it is Colorful Ninja Iromaki.
The second one is Matasaburo on the wind.
And the third one is
simply titled Rebecca.
- So basically these are three films
from the Young Animate Training Projects.
And if you've ever watched
something like Death Billiards
or the original Mi Mi Mi.
Those are films that
came from this project
so by watching them you can
support the anime industry
and that's fucking awesome in my opinion.
- So if you are interested
in the art of Japanese culture
and animation then make sure
to go down to the links
in the description below.
And thank you once again for
sponsoring today's episode.
- So anyway, hope you
guys enjoy this episode.
We've been Trash Taste.
He's got trash mouth or
trash in his mouth right now.
- It actually smells like
Satan empteid his trash
into my mouth.
- I didn't lose
I'm happy I got a good figure.
- I am still surprised that
when we and Connor, drawn
because thank you Rias for like
fucking solo carrying
this play through for me.
- Big titties win.
- And we'll see you guys next time.
- Bye.
- God.
- You could argue that Shonen Jump
is actually not a figure.
Just saying like, I
mean, then I would win.
- Look I already lost, all right.
- Look I wanted to get the top.
He's already dead.
(soft soul music)